but as you mentioned it's it's a fight
movie and the fight scenes are
spectacular i mean they look incredibly
realistic how much physical contact was
there
all physical you know
one of the things i learned from this
director i work with chad celeski on
john wick was if the real performers the
real actors are doing it for real then
you can put the camera anywhere you want
you don't have to create shots to hide
that you don't have the real actors in
the shot right so learning all the
disciplines were key to me and also key
to me was getting the current flyweight
ufc flyweight champion valentina
chefchenko she was my opponent so i got
to really fight her so i had to really
train i trained for about two and a half
years and up my game and really be
prepared for for this moment but
fighting a real fighter was she able to
kind of hold back
sometimes yes sometimes no
on the
day two of the fight it was a five-day
fight sequence and of course we shot
that at the beginning because we had now
trained we were all ready we knew our
choreo and day two into the five-day
fight she uh kicked me and broke two
ribs
and uh she was fired
[Laughter]
but what did that shut down production
or anything or
no it threatened to but i knew that if i
told anyone and told the insurance that
i had broken two ribs they would have
shut me down and i knew that i might
never get back to this movie again and i
put too much into it i'd work too hard
i'd come too far i'd fought too hard so
the funny thing happened because i'd
been training to be a fighter for two
and a half years i think the fighter
side of my training took over and as all
fighters when you're in the ring if you
get injured stopping isn't an option you
just keep going you just have to keep
going so i made the decision to not tell
anybody keep going and once we finish
the fight then i told everybody oh [ __ ]
i think i broke something i have to go
to the hospital
wow
[Music]
you